hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it's
the 16th of May and you're watching
games but you stopped five the show
where we seamlessly combined video games
Australian accents t-shirts with
references and the very best stories of
the week let's go first op Soni have
announced when they'll be holding their
press conference at e3 this year the
date and time has been set for monday
june nine at 6pm pacific time as for
other confirmed exhibitors Microsoft are
covering the morning of june nine with
their conference at nine-thirty a.m.
pacific while EA has that there's been
noon of the same day for all your
nintendo news the very next day at 9am
PST is the time you'll want to keep in
mind in other microsoft d things
upcoming open-world shooter sunset
overdrive is a microsoft exclusive
because the publisher let the dev keep
the rights to the title before insomniac
worked on sunset overdrive and fuse they
were working exclusively with sony and
even though they created franchises like
Ratchet and Clank and resistance they
don't earn the rights to the titles
fortunately Microsoft delivered for them
on this one and all rights remain with
the dev yesterday we got word that far
cry 4 is coming and it seems to be
pretty exciting news for letting you
guys it'll be hitting xbox 360 xbox one
ps3 ps4 and PC on November the 18th it's
set in a fictional region of the
Himalayas which is suffering under the
regime of a despotic self-appointed King
also you reportedly me to use an array
of weapons vehicles and animals to
traverse landscape and write your own
story so sort of like last time but
different
we got the final word on what the
watchdogs console resolutions and frame
rates will be this week and here's
everything you need to know on ps4 the
game will be 900p while on xbox one it's
792 p both will be running at 30 frames
per second cruise director Jonathan
Lauren is asking gamers not to worry too
much about the technical man you sure
and rather trust that they're making the
best decision for the overall gameplay
experience he also talked about the
importance of dynamism a bunch of times
and promised that their technical
choices will deliver the maximum
possible dynamism whatever that means
and in what is certainly the biggest
news of the week the xbox one got a
price cut by removing the controversial
connect should you want to grab the
unbundled version it'll cost you three
hundred and ninety-nine bucks and it
goes on sale from june nine briones can
be made now at amazon best buy and
gamestop if you want to pick one up the
Kinect sensors will be sold separately
so gamers can pick them up afterwards if
they so choose and Microsoft reckons
they will as they're predicting an
upswing in connects sales let me know in
that commenting section down below if
you want your xbox one with a kinect or
not and why this week on site you do
well to check out Danny's phenomenal
house of cards tech on call of duty
watch Bonita and Christmas around
innocence to and find out all the mario
kart 8 details on the gist and that's
everything I want to tell you about this
week as always thanks very much for
watching and I will be back with even
more gaming news on Monday